I'm Victoria de gracia the director of
the European Institute will want to
welcome you today this is how many of
you have never been to an event at the
Lincoln Europeans to do yeah well okay
alright so if you are satisfied but
let's say even if you're not put your
name down and so that we can be in
contact with you now those who are
outside of the New York you know you
could do that but and we will still be
in contact with you okay I wanted very
briefly to introduce our programming for
the year in which that is for this
semester in which today's event inviting
in the Atia transatlantic Academy to
speak to their recent work as part and
then I'll introduce Steven Szabo who's
the executive director of the
transatlantic Academy and then I'll turn
it over to Jane Cohen professor
political science here and to our
colleagues to begin what is in effect a
two-part a discussion of the report
which will take us through to 7:30 so I
wanted to call your attention to the
fact that we've got an ongoing series of
talks lectures which this year is being
organized around the problem of the
European public sphere an old question
but it also a very vexing and a new
question next
it's next Thursday we have abraham de
Swan very distinguished linguist those
political scientists sociologists you
know a polymath emeritus professor from
the social sciences at the university of
an Amsterdam is going to speak about the
more languages the more English on the
language constellation of the EU I can't
tell you how unusual that is a language
is one of the biggest questions how
relatively little discussion there is
both historically in terms of policy
questions and then on October 10th we
have a day-long seminar workshop on
development and under belt development
in post-war Europe focusing a great deal
on European project
in Eastern Europe but also Eastern
European projects globally so it's a
rather an unusual take and then October
13th how fragile Europe to colleagues
Paul Schnabel and Alexander annoy COI
from the University of Amsterdam or our
Queen Wilhemina chairs this year at
Columbia who will be speaking and your
general questions about the European
crisis on that same day I should say no
not October 16th Martin wolf will be
speaking coordinated by our Institute
and the Institute for global economic
governance so do keep an eye out for
these events I'm very pleased today to
introduce members of the fellows and the
executive director of the transatlantic
Academy this is a an institute in
washington d.c a unusual hybrid that is
it's both think-tank that is people are
really thinking and also really studying
there as as scholars but organized
mentored by stephen jaybo the executive
director to investigate approaches to
the long term challenges facing Europe
and North America so the Academy does
this in an unusual way by bringing
together scholars policy experts and
authors from both sides of the Atlantic
from different disciplinary perspectives
and to research and analyze distinct
policy challenge of transatlantic
interests and it's an interesting
problem you know what is a transatlantic
interest whether that really interests
you will have to find those problems
where there could be convergence as
divergences overlaps and even over the
last several years has done a wonderful
job since six years that the project has
been going the first theme immigration
integration the second Turkey and its
neighborhood of several publications
which circulated recirculate global
shift the transatlantic
and the new-new geopolitics already
natural resources a new geopolitical
great game and then the future of the
Western liberal order which is their
2012-2013 report which we're going to be
discussing today I'm sorry and then the
next year the future of the of the
international liberal order that's what
we were discussing today very
fascinating report as we'll see and this
year they're working on religion and the
liberal order and you should know if
you're interested if you want to apply
as a fellow that they're going to be
working on Russia and the West for next
year and they're accepting applications
anyway the transatlantic Academy was
created in 2007 it works in partnership
with the German Marshall Fund of the
United States which is so strongly
supported American Studies of Europe and
should continue to do so and the site's
Jif doing a Boleyn and GERD bucerius as
their other donors as well but we won't
talk about them now I'm very very
pleased to introduce Steven Chabot the
executive director also the intellectual
dinah dinah miser and mentor because
there's a very crucial role in this and
not a simple one that is each individual
scholar expert and so on wants to do his
or her own work and he also wants to
make it been a collective project the
outcome which is a policy but also one
with a great deal of depth and then the
problem is how to get any policymakers
to to listen to it or to read it and
that's a big problem and an interesting
one as well okay Steven
thank you very much Vicki I'd just be
I'll be very brief I just want to also
mention professor de Grazia was I
actually on an evaluation team that we
had she and Kristoff there some a
well-known scholar of and policy analyst
in Germany came to the Academy a couple
of years ago and gave us a really
excellent evaluation about how we can
make it better and what we were doing
right what we're doing wrong so she
knows us very well and thank you for
hosting us today it's a real pleasure to
be here because we really want to bring
I mean the Academy is bringing academic
ideas to policy discussions and I think
what's unusual about it it's not based
at a university it's based at the German
Marshall Fund which is a sort of a think
tank and a convening institution and as
you pointed out I think you described it
very well so I don't have to go into it
very much more to except to say that
today you'll have there'd be three of
our either of current fellows or former
fellows and my Brit who was almost a
fellow before she decided to go to sikri
instead and launching John who was one
of the fellows who did the China chapter
in the report this year unfortunately
couldn't make it so I was very happy to
get my Brit who knows China so well to
come in and talk a bit about and also
being a German and a European to sort of
bring bring that perspective to it as
well so we actually did two reports the
one two years ago was on the problems of
the liberal order at home and it's
called the democratic disconnect and
looked at some of the issues both in the
US and Canada and in Europe in terms of
domestic politics democratic deficits
and all of that and what that meant and
this year we look more at what does it
mean what is the future of the
international liberal order the sort of
Bretton Woods order that was set up by
the US and Europe after World War two
now with the rise of both Democrat
Democratic non Western powers like
Brazil India South Africa but also not
so democratic powers like China and
Russia whether Russia is rising or not
it's another issue but anyway we so
we're looking at sort of where does it
where do we go what is the international
system go in this really pivotal time of
change and the last year is to give you
a quick overview we looked at there's
this whole issue of a polycentric world
not necessarily meaning multipolar maybe
not a polar but polycentric I'm not
more pluralistic world a much less
Western world than we've seen over the
last couple hundred years and what does
that mean for us and I think how do we
manage normative tensions that come out
of having very different types of
political cultures and views of the
international order what kind of a world
do the emerging powers want to have will
they be as Bob Zoellick said responsible
stakeholders and a sort of expand the
Bretton Woods system well they will have
different sort of views about the
international system at all or they've
simply be Free Riders so we discussed a
lot of that and the report you'll see we
have some very good chapters I'm Raziel
and India in particular in South Africa
three Democratic liberal orders but we
have very different views of the
international system one of our fellows
last year is Charlie caption who's now
in the White House working on European
policy at the White House so we take
full credit for promoting him - or maybe
demoting him from academia to the
government but that's really the idea to
bring together ideas - to government we
looked this past year on how do we
strengthen the liberal anchor looking at
things like NATO at TTIP at ways that
the US and Europe can strengthen the
liberal anchor and the most important
thing that we found in both years is
that we have to get our act together at
home that we have to renew our
democracies that we have to deal with
the economic inequalities that are that
are plaguing our societies if we don't
have that what kind of attractiveness do
we have for other countries or other
systems so we looked at that and I won't
go through it now but you can take a
look at the report and you'll be able to
see lots of ideas so with that it's
background are very pleased that we can
do this I'm looking forward to the
discussion and thank you very much for
doing this
thank you yeah so um welcome you can
hear me right yeah all right so I'll
simply introduce our speaker may birth
stream bounces correctly she said at the
end national fun group it's a research
group Asian perceptions of the EU at the
free university of berlin and her
previous positions include senior
research fellow and executive director
of the China and global security program
at the Stockholm International Peace
Research Institute the Fritz Thyssen
fellow at the Weatherhead center of
international affairs at Harvard head of
the International Forum on strategic
thinking on the German council on
foreign relations among others and she
publishes widely in widely may be widely
- on EU security fares towards Asia and
China this panel is titled the liberal
order conceptual and policy approaches
from Europe and China unfortunately and
another panelist Mount Vernon mullah was
unable to make that due to a family
crisis but I'm sure that we'll have an
interesting discussion and our introduce
our commentator
yeah good afternoon thank you very much
for your kind introduction and I care
that I have the pleasure to speak
probably twice as much at the same time
to try to make up for the prison who's
missing but I'll do my best and follow
Ignat challenge thanks very much to the
center in Columbia University for having
me here and also the terms of any
Academy to be here as Steven already
mentioned that I was once supposed to
become a fellow when they're focused in
China now went to Slippery instead I
regret it under today and therefore I
become kind of a transatlantic groupie
and as you see I follow them around the
world so I've been here twice just for
these two lectures yesterday today and I
enjoyed the discussions enormously so
I'm very much looking forward to showing
you a little bit like what's going on on
our side of the Atlantic we speak who
spoke a lot about the u.s. pivot to Asia
and we had a really hard time and we're
still having it in Europe and trying to
explain why that should also matter to
Europe and to all Sixpoint our
transatlantic friends on the other side
why we might have a very different view
on China's rise and the to put it very
bluntly you have the Pacific in between
we have Russia and as you probably heard
with Ukraine crisis that is something
which catches a lot of our attention so
Asia is sometimes is quite far away for
us and this is why the energy is in
existence because when we basically try
to show it's like how its European
efforts to promote security policy to
provide security best practices viewed
in Asian countries particularly as the
European Union tries to promote its
values not by aircraft carriers for
preservation by talking about training
and this is what we actually analyze in
the energy group basically the question
for us is thus Europe matters in
security in an Asian century and I'm
very happy to discuss with you why I
think it should matter also doesn't look
like and not as well we focus on for the
last four years Europe should have a
quick interest in keeping the liberal
international order because we benefit
greatly from it we also benefit greatly
from keeping asia-pacific stable so I'm
gonna
connect both of that and talk today
about the liver international order with
a specific focus and security policy and
cooperation between Europe and China and
the region and security policies to give
one little aspects to talk about the
efforts of the uu to spread good
governance and to promote effective
multilateralism so I'm going to speak
about challenges I'm going to speak
about opportunities and about
instruments in Europe's efforts to keep
the liberal international order we don't
have to clean the to hear okay three
four arguments that I want to do is
basically showing that thanks to adapt
international work itself and the rising
power but it doesn't one's to get rid of
it it has no substitute for the
international work so we are in the time
I basically have a void with the current
eroding liberal order and the West
Chinese corporation can work to address
this array being international order by
what we do face with carbons and
differences in the moon explain a little
bit more what I mean but it secondly I
was just talking about transatlantic
operation the report also goes that
there should be a division of labor
between Europe and Asia when dealing
with the rise of China and I would argue
that you and the US should go for a
division of cost and not of labor well
you should be building on its strengths
and finally that I would say that the
European Union and the US need to
coordinate on policy weeks upon the ones
up promoting best practices how to do
this on adapting the analysis to which
cannot accommodate the emerging powers
on regaining the Goshen Paulo that's
what we discussed basically we have to
get our act together it's going to be in
a position to credible and negotiate our
positions and finally to stay eternity
together
let me quickly introduce the research
group that I'm having and Billy
basically we're team of ten people from
India China and Germany and Europe
that's focused in the interdisciplinary
in an international team on European
security policy to its strategic
partners in the air and China and
increasingly also the asia-pacific
region so we focus on very traditional
security fields peacekeeping and expert
motorola genes and we increasingly focus
also non-traditional challenges by try
to deal with humanitarian it's almost as
natural catastrophes disaster management
but also the whole area water energy
systems of non-traditional challenges we
have a series of publications we've been
working paper series which is a bit more
academic focused with good policy paper
which is more experienced at
quasi-community and then we also did
several conference in Beijing in bed
very very trying to entice and discuss
our findings unsigned abroad two of them
here as examples video but they all
online in case you would like to have a
look at that so this is basically what
we do and a Sunday that I'm here on the
university I thought like we probably
could see a little faded a little
theoretical background February 5 we go
right to the fact after we took probably
to give you an understanding very coming
truck this is the mall that we look at
anyways the European Union if they try
to implant security policy far greater
than India and China as you I think
probably very well aware of new aircraft
carrier we have no higher capabilities
or anything of that sort
but European Europe's can do is
basically to waste his weight to train
try to promote its best practices and we
call this a process of diffusion
diffusion is even variable we see that
others might adapt an alarm on my
rejected when you have no ways of course
no ways of coalition so basically we
have the European Union on the one side
of the emerging global actor who tries
to promote an effective model weather
system and has strategic partnerships in
it in as a tool and has policies in the
area of expertise revisions in the area
of peacekeeper that a tricep removed
basically how to do certain things on
the other side we have commuting powers
like India and China who have a very
timely demand of finding solutions the
extra controls user has been introduced
in young China the mid 2000 it's
relatively new and better clean up today
that end of the time like 50 years to
develop their own system but they're
looking for templates worldwide and the
Yoakum Union tries to sell their
template when you look at the security
concept both powers have moved from a
non-alignment policy very much to
becoming more active joining
multilateral institutions joining
peacekeeping missions look in the of
course has a long tradition of that but
try asking a very new power in
peacekeeping operations supporting
multilateralism also in the sinning
policies and what we are looking at is
basically at the sea fusion on both
sides and we say they're the mechanisms
direct means
waves for the open Union tries to
actively push the other side to accept
there are the norms by engaging the
other song
reservation by implants for working
working groups together you will see
later we work with over 60 working
groups with China all issues from
aviation to food security but trying to
promote a suit to reapply to do things
but you also have in direct competition
lesson during mimicry basically China
and India but also others they have it
leads to final solution relative with me
to a problem and then you could see this
is how the others are doing like India
Docks
probably a second approach that might be
an incentive to approach of the China
side lesson drawing you see works when
of use it or maybe create you pretend to
do it that way without really lenient or
we look at this at this process and then
fulfilled the factors in between so
basically to what extent US culture
really play a role to extend this
history play alone Europe very often the
argument is we cannot become active in
asia-pacific because we're from a
colonial powers so they didn't want to
talk to us in terms of training you know
that's a matter if they Sedition make us
make it said that I have you patient in
the United States over there wings to
Europe in terms of protected context
doesn't make a difference if this is a
one-party state or democracy
hello I'm sorry short our findings have
shown in action history doesn't really
play a major role it's used as a
rhetorical tool but actually if the
template fits it doesn't really matter
what any context does another clinical
China has about been much more from the
using partisan in near Heston and also
education like something growth so if
this matter in faction decision-makers
have been trained in the United States
where you probably know more real
something that if you join the European
publicly more about crisis prices versus
constructivism so that's a very short
Lucas and I just want many pieces to
that because it might explain you a
little bit like where we coming from so
I was reading of they report about the
post how to keep a little ordering
across Western world and what we try to
look at basically what can Europe do to
promote an order that it has thrive
within so well to continue doing that
and this is what I want to talk with you
about when I talk very quickly about
common difference between the EU and
China I want to talk about the
annotation challenges to the liberal
order the tools we have at hand and then
very specifically in the small case
study the corporation security fields to
see what is possible and that the image
and I will tell you about the challenges
you always know what can go wrong the
German for that is Canadian video which
means like a carrier concerns so I'm use
due to our brutality and then we go to a
more positive outlook and food solution
communes desert differences one
interesting thing is that we said very
often herbal or conceptual gaps we think
that we talk about the same issues
because we use the same terminology but
actually mean very different things
I guess when you've been the wolf your
local council and a corporation that is
probably one of the major issues that we
look so similar that we maybe are very
similar but actually not demons that I
would like to be spied on right
Americans I'm dancing at the problem
each spy useful everybody I like that
the problem that's like how you spell
that to the people because he have very
different ideas about this the same gets
in the tubes are like city to
partnership I think when you talk about
the United think about strategic it's
very often has a military component
when you're talking China Basiji
partnership we have a whole list for
they expectantly communion with revive
may have a list and then also she should
be now speaks about the comprehensive
security partnership as a whole is
through Europeans it's more like we are
really serious focus and respect we see
so now it's one point by the EU diplomat
who was asked like what the strategic
partnership in the moment said nothing
like that you know it once you're in it
little conceptual defense thinking about
multi-level was the multipolarity right
in mm there was a lot to talk about
oh we actually share the same values
because the Europeans want to have a
more effective multilateral system right
by the Chinese side like they want to go
for multiple areas small little mix of
ladders - it actually is very different
right Mongol analyst means that you find
together solution is a very
institutionalized way and primarily
among democracies while Michael
activation Museum just several posts
making position doesn't really knew that
this is institutionalized in any way or
the other thing about intervention and
non-interference if you think about
wastin security policy discourses for
the last 20 years it has been very much
about humanitarian intervention you
violate the sovereignty of mistake by
going in there to fix it the whole idea
but fresh off a of families things is
about interference why China and also
Indian other countries insists of not
interference like a very realistic
paradigm ignore missus our permit the
stupidly you do not interfere so we
start with cognitive differences when we
discuss cooperation and that
one of the fish stumbling blocks
secondly perceptions differ when you ask
in China those are very nice Paul about
what do you think first what do you
think about you and yes what do you
think for a swim you okay so the Chinese
are the first thing that I've noticed a
few fold a power supper which was pretty
baked and then luxury goods so basically
it is it is a very cliche thinking about
you are basically equal to u equals the
Euro equal to eight products Europe
itself is not really a political power
center right it seems plenty walk we're
not as a political power center and when
you talk with them about security policy
and they say like well still a long way
to go
the Libya intervention changed a little
bit because apparently T's you know do
this kind of stuff but it's still a long
way to go but Europeans when they look
at China they think about trying there's
a big trade partner they accept that
there's a big power shift oh it's the
Asia Pacific and there is talk about
non-proliferation issues non-traditional
security threat but still you have the
tiring existence
you still have like Russia and a lot of
problems in between so you perceive each
other as murali it straight Curtis not
really as partisan to work with in
security issues talking about a tie to
adapt the liberal order to those
challenges
next point is like we also have like a
new and also already you know challenges
there the questions like how can we
collaborate over one of the most debated
one is about cybersecurity
security and you have the EU code of
conduct and how to deal with
cybersecurity while you have a Chinese
car coming to have you internet security
and the look quite similar at the
beginning right they just have this
little the flint-like fight where it's
which basic reason that code of conduct
which for the 20s for Russia but also by
some Central Asian states folks it's
very much of keeping state control over
the flow of information while the
European one is much more about making
it a safe way to interact originally in
other areas in cyberspace so you have to
know just very little differences but
that actually makes big stumbling block
wider from that point so easily a common
approach also probably when you talk
about the strategic distress also I
guess the assumption that the other side
is probably the least perpetrator does
really help company working group
although they serve working group
between the yueqin Union and China on
the Asya and cyber security but it's not
really moving forward because it's just
a lack of a common approach and Trust
take development aid when you look at
Africa the European Union and its member
states providing more than 50% of the
development aid over there but also
becoming increasingly very dollars an
actor but having a very different
approach so that Europeans call it the
good governance which also sounds very
nice they're very often present working
while the Chinese put against an
effective governance right so it's very
similar words but actually you do need
to discuss in detail what do you mean by
it to find out can we actually
collaborate so when you initially have
this declaration sounds like oh yeah we
really mean the same but if you go more
into details theory LX that's a very
different notation for their B's so what
are the tools we have in hand right talk
about what it's like the difference is
how we perceive things in a very
different way we see each other in a
different way how we approach issues in
a different way one of the tools we have
at hand might be a Buddha call it's
between Europe and Juma's too tiring
existence and the primacy of trades and
we work on trade issues but for
everything else to be a little bit too
far away
looking at their shrinking defense
budget in Europe and also the political
will that just just somewhere else about
particularly in your neighborhood
Europe has no morality the tools of
preservation of trying to work the way
we moves together to say like this might
be a good way to go forward of capacity
building I spoke about this also
management at the beginning humanitarian
assistance of the Europeans
trying to put a know how best practices
and how to cope with resources that has
been relatively successful because for
ourselves a rather new experience by
this management is a really new thing in
Europe of a supranational level and
that's something you can do capacity
building when you think about the odds
and the criteria that Europeans paid to
build up the press work of the authors
criteria to build up capacity but also
Europeans have been very good including
technology over there for the last 30
years to spur on the economic
development and also we can do is
engaging in this kind of multilateral
regimes working together on issues and
that's when I'm wasted
the Union you have 28 states and once
that have no territory interested Asian
Pacific which probably also my top is a
tool to think about 20 different ways to
collaborate and when you do a lot of
these preservation and engaging in
sexual dialogues in the e level you have
dialogues and 24 areas ranging a step
before navigation to food security
employment Social Affairs maritime
securing these are all issues that might
be of interest and you have more than a
hundred people rather than daily basis
with China and on the German side you
have 70 sexual BIOS upgrade also within
all areas of government with your
countries you do this in a bigger
framework in the European Union there is
in China 2020 strategic agenda that have
been concluded last year which covers
all area of collaboration between both
sides including peace and security
prosperity and sustainable development
of giver to people exchanges as a really
great flavor and Juman sites you have
the support to mean Chinese innovation
partnership we have annual biannual
government consultations between China
and Germany that's the only format the
China is doing with another country in
that way five minutes and and we work on
all kind of areas so this framework of
innovation partnership now is an attempt
to also have those tricky issues in
there to be discussing one common
framework so you do not talk like either
about the world law were about
commercial aspects are trying to put
them a bit more in the common room
finally cooperation and security policy
fields there is there a lot of nothing
risks that I would say a very promising
cooperation going on in the field of
maritime security you trade SC foreign
to 95% so there's a big interest in
actually securing maritime security that
has been a
the new police in cooperation with China
also the area of responsibility to
protect they have no discussion although
there's a lot of disagreement of course
a lot of the opium say why shall we deal
with security name of the city that's
only part far away the American feel but
we do have an impact in terms of
security because you have the specific
the highest expenditure on arms and you
have the European companies to deliver
quite a big deal of that we do
collaborate in the celeriac tomorrow
studies in peacekeeping on expert
control says you can see like China has
been a very active contributor to you
admissions it's like week number
fourteen in the moment but also next
week controls to have been increasing
collaboration between both sides this is
just an example really for promoting the
governor's here to promote the other
sides to join in those groups to make
the world a safer place
finally challenges so I talked to you
like about difference we might have
difference of perceptions the tools and
time to specific fields you could work
together on which are all touched upon
in this report but the challenge
remained on the one side and that was
exceedance of beginning getting their
act together and that's really the
question about prosperity so as far as
we are in a weakened position to make
with the Europe rise in Europe and
really have the problem within one side
you don't really kind of what's an actor
over there on the other side you have
all the essential thinkers in Europe
because it doesn't help but whose
resources
secondly it seems to be a challenge to
cooperate in 2006 sales are any you
us-style ik and security in East Asia
that hibernated immediately off
convinced again
you have a lot of people in the US of
plankton ager never been to Europe right
you have a lot of people are used to
have lips like this in Europe
now you may but you most people don't
talk to each other I talk to people in
Washington get retrained up with your
penis to eveness but it's not really
that there would be a lot of
Incorporation fight we have different
perceptions of China because you join
America's we never I'm sure between and
also we have ongoing transatlantic
quarrels over TTIP and London and spying
another area so we do need to get our
act together to analyze or to accept we
do need to each other and then finally
we do need each other because we have a
very typical partner on the other side
filthy planner and the last 18 months to
shipping has been very active in
consolidating his power and you have a
lot of gymnastic challenges there so
it's not the easiest partner net product
to deal with because he has only limited
ways of being flexible himself in that
period so this transatlantic cooperation
necessary so to complete when I try to
show you is that basically when we talk
about the level of order in a post
Western world and the rise of China and
the effect of this and how this is super
Europe you side you can say that mean
you can say you can see China is trying
to adapt international order to fit into
fine boys but it doesn't want to erase
it
it's actually room to operate and to
restore the solidity of international
order but we face a lot of challenges
one of them being that we have copies of
differences secondly when you could of
coordinate transatlantic between the EU
and the US we probably should go for a
division of tasks but not of labor with
the EU building on the strength of
available and finally the u.s.
coordination would be necessary on the
policy mixing the wants of promoting
best practices like an expert control
today there was a seminar and the junior
high is talking about controls and a lot
of extra control programs in China the
US EU outreach to have more cooperation
to see like you know what can we
exchange on this but also to work
together and adapting the system on this
and then regaining Miyoshi pea power by
getting your act together and then
staying commutator Bruce Bogert of the
Stanford who is the Stanford C Bernstein
and company I don't know what that means
professor of leadership and ethics at
Columbia Business School he has been a
research fellow and visiting professor
at the Ecole Polytechnique social
science research center Berlin Stockholm
School of Economics Humboldt University
Singapore Management University etc he's
finishing a project sponsored by your
European consortium on the complexity of
the evolution of venture capital and a
collective book involving more than 20
researchers on the small worlds of
national and global corporate governance
do you want to come
sure okay but are you using that no okay
we're not gonna stay to go very much
okay I guess Voltaire said that uh
history is tricks played upon the dead
resumes tricks played upon the living
the and that's especially an old an old
resume but you did a great job with it
but the nice thing the booking on the
books over projects over it was actually
on it's called the small worlds of
governance in the world and maybe I'll
make an allusion to that and I also
spent two years ago in Berlin I say this
for some Berlin to some my German
friends at the business office coleg
where there were a lot of German lawyers
I never understood how important law is
to the at least to some German thinking
about the about the world I read this
report it's a it's a great overview it's
challenging to make a comment on such a
you know a comprehensive report and I
won't try to do that I would say some
issues about what struck me on this the
it was you know I was the clerk of
science said at Berkeley there was a
fellow named do Wang Ming Wei Ming do I
don't know if he ever heard of him he's
an interesting fellow who talked about I
became an advisor later to Singapore's
now I'd actually Beijing University
because at Harvard who was that Berkeley
and now he's in in China who talked
about Confucianism efficient order and
etc and so on I found that chapter in
China to be really interesting I felt
that was a great attempt to take what it
might mean to think about the world from
a different perspective and then to kind
of explain it whether it's correct or
not it's not it's not my issue here but
I felt that was a important thing to do
when you're trying to figure out what
that order might be and we're saying
that China is going to be a big a big
player in it
the
a liberal order took me a while to
figure out what that meant because you
know liberals one of those words which
doesn't translate well even when you're
speaking the same language whether it's
the UK or the US or elsewhere where
liberal can mean the economic system
which part of the report was about but
it also can mean liberal in terms of
politics or can be you know John Stuart
Mill and John Locke etc and that in that
tradition so you know there was a number
of things happen tonight and then I was
and I was thinking going back to this
issue of thinking about the world with
these new players coming in with the
conversation about the Brooks you know
what would liberal actually mean to
these players and I felt that you know
and I was trying to figure and what
would we actually want you know clearly
trade should be liberal formed
investment should be liberal was a nice
discussion on exchange rates why China
you'd think would want to move it
towards their currency but understands
the cost and benefits for a rational
approach etc and you know it's probably
roughly correct we can you know is lots
of reasons to be concerned about Russia
these days but Russia is probably an
annoying factor more than a really
determining factor at this point is
impaired to to China and someone like me
who hoped for India as well be part of
that dialogue given their important
democratic tradition no matter what we
actually observe in that democracy and
you know I think you know what would the
u.s. want you know you know we probably
would want some things which you know
which we should make sense to us in
terms of you know if someone who's not
aggressive someone who's a friend you
know someone who is who was basically
not threatening the neighborhood and you
mentioned these these these things you
know should the US care that it's it's
internally liberal not the struck me is
not a certain you know you could could
you have a liberal order globally which
does not in a kind of fractal sense
break down to every single country in
community
the in the world i its aspect and would
hope that is the case but you only went
beyond that and what you really asked us
to do is to say what could the US and
Europe actually learn from China and
elsewhere about what this order should
be and the report I think I think this
is fair did it didn't give that a lot of
play and I think that deserves play
maybe it's not really that bad of a
world after all
so this sort of Confucian hierarchy
notion out there strikes this is kind of
bad because hierarchy sounds like
there's going to be one person at top of
the hierarchy
Confucianism actually was you know
feudal set of families etc is really
poly ARCIC to use your expressions and
one can imagine different centers of the
earth you know being under their own
hierarchy and yet building an order
which could be quite well well
functioning and that wouldn't dance be
the worse the worst vision I wanted loss
to point to something else you spend in
the port which is very interesting was
this word normative just one of the
things I do actually is you know is
build little models of diffusion of
things rather bore you about how that
actually works but though it's it's I
get little excited when I talk about
that the Norman of Howard normative
actually work the diffusion fusion from
where and so it had a presumption which
it was defusing from a center out again
from Europe which maybe is a great
presumption but it may not work that way
then they work in an entirely different
way but what struck me is that diffusion
usually works through some sort of
contact as via contact mechanism on this
so I think I mentioned to a few of you I
was Louis Ettinger's research assistant
you don't know who probably who he is
but elites that works Karl Deutsch etc
seems like a long time ago but you think
about this global elite and you know
you're after world war two with you know
and Julie teen Schuman and afterwards
all speaking German to each other that
was the language which they had in
common what is the language which
actually is the international language
these days we say it's the more
languages the more we speak English I
can understand why that's that what that
would work well it's not an English
which maybe be you know semantically
endowed with the same meaning which we
wish think it uh we think it has and
when I look even at the economic order
so we did this book this is why I pour
into this book a project a little bit
you think that you have these
multinational corporations which are
around the world when you look at their
boards or even their ownership ownership
is a little bit more international but
the boards are largely national it's not
as if you've got you know lots of people
on these boards who are foreign this is
true even within Europe that the German
boards are still primarily German French
boards they're speaking French speaking
English these days but this SIL barley
by and large you know French French
boards which are operating you know the
right thing which maybe they can do is
add a few women to those things but as
long as they're German women for German
boards or a Norwegian woman from the
Norwegian boards you can be doing pretty
it's pretty much the the order so you
can't really turn to a private ordering
like our friends in the law school would
say to solve these problems is this not
the social fabric of which we found even
in post-war Europe after that terrible
invent it does not exist in the in the
in this in this global environment is it
produced by international agencies I
don't think it is produced by
international agencies so I'm less
optimistic about a normative
understanding being reached as something
having to do with a just a a tolerance
if you wish for different normative
understandings and I think that's where
we really are in this world and I don't
think that's the worst of all of all
outcomes there's no reason to even
perhaps desire a global normative order
as long as as sense a basic tolerance
for these for these differences so I
thought this was a you know
report if I can imagine the Chinese
developing their report and Singapore
doing there is in India doing there is
and each one I can call it you know the
liberal order or whatever anybody might
call it but they probably wouldn't be
mirror images each other and that that
would be the interesting dialogue to
take a document like this and then think
about other players in the world and how
they would describe that I bet they're
far apart but perhaps that's the
necessary steps to overall understanding
so forgive me for not going down to the
exact details but time is short and I
thought this overall perspective might
be of some value to you thank you yeah I
open with a just one or two questions of
my own and then go on because I also was
unclear about what liberal order how one
understands liberal order and what
challenged in this post Western world
and more importantly what's worth
preserving so so I mean in one place in
the report one lists liberal democracy
industrial capitalism secular
nationalism and open trade now of course
even the step stages of a little of the
so-called liberal order since World War
two were very different when you had a
more kind of social democratic
understanding and what I don't like the
word but a more neoliberal and these are
not the same species and using the word
liberal for both is desire but but the
other serious question is also that I
mean of course we know that this this
order included so the democracies that
were also empires so there was hierarchy
was just in a different sort and it also
included actors states that were not
democracies it was that's what
pluralistic meant there was never one so
I mean what's not new is that there are
states that are not democracies an init
or even that states that are not
democracies that are powerful since the
USSR was
certainly couldn't because of being
democratic but it was pretty we thought
it was powerful
so we discovered it wasn't so I think
the question is is that it's important
or to sort of figure out what we mean by
by a liberal order in a post Western
world I'm still confused on what what's
on what you what is meant by that and
and at the same time I'm also I also
think that this issue of getting our own
house in order if we're going to be
diffusing anything is really central
because it could be you say there was no
there's not much issue about
post-colonial stuff but but I I wonder
if the meaning and the validity of
liberal and democratic principles are
that compelling when they're not
disaggregated disassociated from the
strategic use of these words and of the
problem and and some rather alarming
practices that were done in on the part
of these so-called liberal democracies
in the name of liberalism and democracy
and spreading it and civilization and
all of this when actually something else
was going on so I just I just suspect
that this sort of that that the question
yeah we're in a post Western world that
convincing or we're moving towards one
but that simply means that it could
simply mean that once British and then
American hegemony is over and so the
question is is is how to understand what
work liberal is doing all of this but I
guess I'll just I don't know what I'm
supposed to do now I guess I'll just
leave it and ask and so that's for
reflection nobody has to answer that and
unless they want to so questions
the series which states and you think my
piece for eternity distance to sort of
elip or innovate new mechanisms or
strategies to the influence the
sequester y-you mean my spare which
which days are most like afflicted by
the tyranny of distance but
disenfranchised like a
which space of most influence well you
can answer and then we're going thank
you thanks so much I'm not entirely sure
if I got your rights of which theory of
distance basically which states probably
do not feel affected by the tyranny of
distance or I would say I mean think
about Europeans the least affected by
tyranny of distance are the British and
some example French and the British and
I think both of them because they still
left you to their their their history of
being like more global powers more I
have a strategic outfit it's also when
you look for someone China based in
those countries have the best China
expertise in their country so I would
say they are think more into the global
terms the British also where the common
walls have been a bit more global
thinking with a special relationship for
the United States and currently they
revived their five power defence
agreement in the era of asia-pacific so
and the French also because of their
former colonies ever more of globalized
like I would say the other some European
the European Union is pretty much a
regional power because we serve estates
over a regional outlook and I think
Germany is just recently being pushed
and pull to become more globally active
also not in a foreign policy sense and I
think you see a very interesting
development in the moment to how too
many arrests like what they call the geo
economic power was like a similar quite
compile a lot of economic power is now
trying to get a more of a global I had
look in politics but I as a dreamin
still working on it I also would like to
respond very quickly to to what both of
you Saturday for if I may I think very
very interesting points and also some
that we've been thinking like that the
whole issue about diffusion was really
exactly about this to see it's a two-way
process right it goes from both ways
it's like to simplify other research
it's structured like this but actually
there is also they sir this feedback
loop because I do I agree with you it
goes in both directions and one of the
key issues that we found that is really
the contact so those people who have
actually been in touch with people at
school you know being being educated at
the same places having traveled that
makes a big difference and particularly
in the last exam on my side you expert
said I met in China for like 15 years
have now been 10 years been able to
travel more and you get a completely
different set of like how to understand
the other side particularly before they
only read the textbooks of whether you
can Union where everything works well
right and then when you meet people you
see it's it's a bit different so I would
agree very much that this is a big big
aspect they're losing the contract and
last but you said about which also goes
with your tolerance but also the values
I think that the most important part and
the moment is to say I think the West
spend a lot of time there saying
basically our our order it's the best
and if you only download far enough you
will read it and I think they're there
the important thing in the moment is to
disentangle those big norms into their
fragments what they actually say like
why is this attractive I had discussion
with a Chinese friend of mine why the
rule of law might be a good idea and he
said like oh you know this is such a
Western concept now it's like well you
know just put the Western thing away and
just think about you have a big
anti-corruption campaign if you go in a
certain level in a Chinese company you
will always have a political function
here probably sitting there so if you
try that company probably doesn't work
too well in terms of like environmental
polluting standards and you want to go
against that and you have like you know
our independent duty could leave
somewhere who could judge over that you
know that's what you never I'd probably
just go to the party central in that in
that village it will undermine those
efforts so it's not about a Western
concept or not is just a question how
can you control power basically and how
can you entrust thumb more power and
then check up on them and I think these
are the kind of issues that way there we
need to go is not to say like I would be
so
superior values but we need to go back
to explain why we think they work and
this is what I'm trying to say we're
this diffusion the training the idea is
like we cannot go and say like you know
you should have ducked this because it's
a better way and I think the Europeans
had a very sobering moment in 2008-2009
with financial crisis we're not that
superior anymore we realize that and I
think by this madam it's just I think a
good learning lessons for like I think
the liberal order whatever might be you
know ligatures - Steven - probably
detail that better what that meant
because I was part of the study but the
idea is that we think of that order is
the best way how it might work in a
peaceful manner to collaborate we need
to on one side adjust it to integrate
the new powers but on the other side to
explain why it is attractive not by like
take it or leave it but this is why it's
effective so I think that is amazing
what could yourself
and if in fact we in fact a lot of kinds
of arrangements do seem to occur
regionally so given China's tensions
with most of its early neighbors how do
they strike how do they get beyond those
territorial issues and sort of chance
standoff that they have and strike some
sort of regional balance with their
neighbors and could you sort of speak
are you able to speak more to that that
part of the report I don't think you're
a part of it just about the notion of
leading hopefully to multilateralism
which seems to be almost hopelessly
complex after christina was maybe this
used too much oh just just very briefly
i'm china you know on the eastern on
this eastern flank you know the western
pacific they do have territorial
disputes so that's why they said okay
we're hemmed in we have all this tension
so it's kind of a zero-sum at this
moment so they're pivoting west so
they're going the other direction they
have this march were strategy and you
know sue with the shanghai cooperation
organization they've you know resolve
territorial disputes in 1996 with the
shanghai 5 which became the SEO in
australia Cooperation organisation in
2001 so they don't have the issue on
their western flank you know and chinese
strategist talk about you know we're not
just a maritime power were also a
Eurasian continental power so while they
have this this tension in the western
pacific they're pivoting west they're
going across Eurasia and Xi Jingping
actually you know his centerpiece of his
foreign policy is the Silk Road economic
belt and this was launched in came out
interesting why may so they were just
you know working on on a Eurasian
integration into connectivity the Silk
Road economic build with the Central
Asian countries with you know Eurasia
building a rail well a lot of Railways
and also accompanying that is the
maritime Silk Road as well so so they're
you know buying up a lot of seaports
around the military the Indian Ocean
littoral and also the Mediterranean
littoral they have a lot of them
infrastructure projects bargain-basement
prices that they procured in the euro
zone crisis after math of the euro zone
crisis so they actually are have a lot
of strategic infrastructure projects
building seaports and you know an
operational control of these seaports in
a Mediterranean the turo and also the
Indian Ocean littoral so they're
pivoting west
the transatlantic trade and investment
partnership given the failure of Doha
you wouldn't eat it and effect become
exclusionary pulling the West together
but excluding not limited to so many
regulation and the such as trade
regulation or is it a step to try to
reinvigorate WTO and open that was the
tension and that was the key issue in
discussions on that yes so two chapters
argue each other okay I think I would
take one more short question then or you
tell me when are we supposed to end yeah
I want any mother you tell me I'd like
to ask me if you could say a few words
about the role of civil society actors
and maybe especially in the light of the
recent events in Hong Kong to what
extent Chinese civil society plays serve
an autonomous rule that is hardly
predictable by Western foreign policy
and that sort of complicated you know a
lot of international relations issue at
this point yeah I think I'm one language
barrier in the moments to understand
like you use a lot of very complex
substantive words yeah
the same Julie to what extent is the
syrup in foreign policy is specifically
or at the Western partnership designed
to work together in the Asian you know
in the Asian world have to take into
account and roll it up for the rising
civil society okay there's neither
controllable by the Chinese states nor
by international agreements yeah for
example civil society you yeah across
countries a global society might be
merging yeah complicates yeah yeah well
I think it's it's probably it's two
different things what about civil
society and then the other part of it
like civil society playing a role in
security policy because the issue of our
security policy it's always been very
conclusive to a small group of decision
makers and so of course it does affect
the society as such it is a thing I
really influenced by civil society
actors I would say in general when you
see on the European side that they've
always been a very promotional policy to
a civil society as far as it is possible
because as you know yourself and the
Chinese side you don't have NGOs you've
got Gong goes government and
non-government organizations and you
have a of poisoning increasing
interconnectedness bye-bye Weibo and and
their own there in social services their
social media services but I think it's
also it's interesting to see the
differences between what's going on in
Hong Kong was going on in the rest of
China and I would say that Hong Kong is
very own story in the moment of what you
see on the twenty so that the
suppressant use so that the rest of the
country will not rise and will not
probably get in that kind of direction I
think on the European side we very much
promote when you look for example we
have Erasmus Mundus Plus which twice -
it has no the highest numbers of Chinese
students coming to Europe and for the
time being also in year it's number two
and all that and that has been increased
we have a lot of EU centuries building
up there there is a lot of whatever can
be done in in the area so I don't think
it's seen as a complicating factor for
security
and Deborah's over there and in terms of
cooperation I would like to put one part
two to your question what you said about
the territory distance talking about
security and that it's like I think it's
two thing one thing is that what's China
see on the eastern side is you're either
due west on the eastern part of thing on
the one side they're very legitimate
desire for a security so they do feel
threatened they do you feel that they
have a necessity to keep an open access
to the maritime routes and then you look
at the nine dash lines basically that
that could also be seen as like an over
exerted expression of security because
if that would actually come true you do
have the open access to two maritime
routes and what you have partition thing
is promoting are an Asian security
architecture by Asians so basically
trying to promote the idea we we have a
collective security where we work
together on this but you have satiric
distress that this just doesn't happen
with the other neighbors but on the
other side what it's a bit more varying
a thing that's one size lie about being
secure and of course that means you have
an insecure power and that is always a
problem because they might overreact the
problem is that you also have on the
other side of the comes back to your
civil society if they're raising a
rising nationalism in the area
particularly in China particularly would
come in as McKenna really to no longer
deliver on communist promises but
nationalism is one of the substitutes it
can under growth and and nationalism and
I think that is the other problem in the
movement that all these claims that have
been put out there it's very difficult
to withdraw and to make a make a
compromise it has been different with
the system from my conference back then
and the Shanghai Cooperation
Organization when they when they
regulated those territory difference
disputes the border disputes I think
it's much more difficult to date
withdrawal from these kind of clients so
you see your and more assertive power
but you see also national is employing
in the role that might be tipping the
balance and I think last but not least
about your tone of society I think the
problem is really in which age group
you're looking
you know if you look at those this
patriotic education for the last 15
years and and also what they put out as
medicines or if you look to those so
older I feel up to those in a road so
it's not that clear-cut to which group
you're referring to
first of all the surprised you said you
didn't was so perfect it's almost like
God I got the Chris see what said how'd
you know he was he was it was a
foreigner and said this English was too
perfect you know I think it's a good
excellent question
it's a really good question
you know the unit was again a chapter in
the report on the internet without
regulation sinners know it's you know
and it's also stings there's people
studying in the US twos there was the
studies done on Twitter hunkered is
Twitter about for mobilizing people and
the answer is it's not particularly good
for mobilizing people it's good for you
information is pretty good but actually
does not lead to collective action focus
because things like Twitter and really
not a social network it has a bunch of
people which get you should get news the
actions I think this is I think this is
still true it's still fairly local but
it could be you know this news or maybe
it's emerged but I think I liked other
poor and you see this like this new this
paper article back to that article a on
Russia about building its own Internet
and you know you have foreigners who
live in China you know the hell they
don't VPNs etc to get their information
on that but this but who do you think is
gonna win on that it's not clear a
liberal order if we define that actually
would win from that it could be it could
be the other the other direction so I
think it's a great question yes still so
unresolved I've I said one point on this
I can't with civil society go without
saying something so you're talking about
the public sphere the media of
communication you I think we talk I mean
of course the related video to my
movements and actors from below
associations movements not transnational
NGOs and NGOs they're always I always
says this is the wrong word for this but
that's another discussion in any case
you know the
problem is that from getting our house
in order democratization perspective and
and diffusion of course take something
like Hong Kong it's those kinds of
actions of civil society look like they
are and we mean just ideally
invigorating maintaining expanding
deepening democracy from the perspective
of well the forces of order it doesn't
look that way it looks like chaos and
you need to take control this isn't this
is a major difference but it is not an
east-west difference we have those
divisions right here first point second
point is that there are you know what
has to think of uncivil Society as well
there are movements transnational that
that mobilize and one of them calls them
themselves now estate Isis but they
weren't initially so there are some
dimensions of this that are not
necessarily echoing what you said they
don't always work in a positive
direction so it's a it's a complicated
situation well I guess so we should I
was told to end it's it's it's a quarter
after you have to make up your mind
thank you very much it was a it was a
wonderful discussion and I guess we move
do we take a break or we do move to the
next panel yes so so well thank you very
much